[Musique]
bienvenue la vie s'anime sur le campus
urbain paris saclay tv vous fait
découvrir tous ces lieux qui émerge un
peu partout sur le territoire
nous voici sur la place hubert coudane
dit la place du lieu de vie c'est un
carrefour de vue stratégique
tout a été fait pour faciliter les
échanges les rencontres entre tous ceux
et toutes celles qui étudient qui
enseigne qui vivent sur le campus urbain
cet endroit s'intègre dans le paysage
tout comme le nouveau bâtiment
d'enseignement de la physique ashba qui
réunira plus de mille étudiants
ce bâtiment le voici il vient d'être
inauguré tout comme les équipements
publics du quartier de moulon parc
mairie annexe groupes scolaires centres
de loisirs ou unis crèche tous ces
services viennent à vous et bientôt
c'est un lycée international qui va
ouvrir ses portes ce sera la rentrée
2021 à palaiseau paris saclay tv vous
fait donc découvrir tous ces nouveaux
lieux et à la fin cette émission comme
d'habitude notre agenda pour ne rien
rater de tous les événements qui se
déroulent sur votre territoire
cette place se veut à l'image du campus
urbain de paris saclay ouverte sur le
monde c'est un lieu d'échangés de
rencontres entre les étudiants et les
chercheurs
elle a été inaugurée en même temps que
le bâtiment d'enseignement physique page
barre plus de dix mille mètres carrés
pour réunir 1000 étudiants
l'objectif est de faire converger toutes
les filières les installations sont high
tech
la vue est imprenable sur la forêt et
juste devant il y a des estives quel
roman
cette journée d'inauguration est
particulièrement importante puisque lé
couple est en fait au colloque à limbe
russie qui est donc un colloque qui vise
à permettre aux étudiants de l3 et de m1
de s'orienter ensuite dans la suite de
leurs études en master 2 et en doctorat
donc c'est une
j'aurais très importante pour la
physique également donc au titre du
terme de l'inauguration du bâtiment
puisque ce bâtiment est l'aboutissement
d'un projet qui a éclos il est à peu
près une dizaine d'années l'idée étant
en fait deux
rapprocher tous les enseignements à
laurent donc de la fin de la licence au
master en un lieu unique
sur le campus or c'est saclay ce qui
permet donc de faire converger toutes
ces différentes filières d'enseignement
de physique qui sont extrêmement large
à orsay dans ce lieu dédié il dispose
donc de plusieurs salles de td plusieurs
dizaines de salles de travaux pratiques
avec des équipements dédiés et également
des plateformes expérimentales dans
lesquelles sont
présent des équipements qui viennent de
matériel de recherches qui vont est donc
destiné à la formation des étudiants est
également une coupole d'observation
astronomique donc la vocation de ce
bâtiment est de réunir en un lieu unique
l'enseignement dans les diverses
matières
enseigner donc à orsay et de permettre
également aux étudiants et bien de
faciliter leur interaction avec les
différents laboratoires qui sont
présents notamment à proximité de ce
bâtiment sur le plateau est également un
peu plus loin soit dans la vallée ce
conte un peu plus loin sur le plateau
notamment des laboratoires de
l'université du cnrs et du cea bâtiment
il a été conçu pour tenir sa place sur
la saison à la place du lieu de vie don
qui la firent une stature sur la plage
du lieu de vie c'est le fond de cette
place mais si l'avenir sa stature aussi
il ne pèse pas trop longues et des
hanches ils laissent passer la lumière
et il va permettre parce déhanchements
de laisser percevoir la ligne d très
belles lignes d arbres de la forêt qui
fait que la nature fait de
l'architecturé l'architecturé vient
aider à constituer la ville qui est très
proche de cette nature qui s'opposent à
cette nature
[Musique]
c'est une place centrale puisqu'elle se
trouve effectivement au carrefour de
plusieurs aujourd'hui livraison de
bâtiments il ya donc la place du lieu de
vie aujourd'hui très animé qui accueille
beaucoup d'étudiants au quotidien vous
avez effectivement le bâtiment
d'enseignement effectivement de la
physique inauguré aujourd'hui donc cette
place sera en permanence une place de
croisement d'animation des étudiants ce
qui est un pur no 1 un élément est
évidemment centrale d'animation des
quartiers que nous produisons sur sur le
quartier manière plus générale nous
avons aussi livré très récemment un peu
plus loin à côté de l'école centrale
mais aussi de le ms l'école nationale
supérieure les premiers logements
familiaux au rez de chaussée des bientôt
vont arriver les premiers commerces du
quartier de moulins qui feront
évidemment le complément à ce qui vient
d'être livrée sur le quartier des écoles
polytechniques juste l'autre côté qui
sont déjà une
les premiers lieux de vie très actif en
ce moment sur sur le quartier sur
lesquels les gens évidemment s'appuie
pour pour vivre au quotidien donc la vie
s'anime largement aujourd'hui sur notre
notre campus urbain et cette place est
un nouvel exemple de l'animation
complète que nous réalisons juste
derrière moi vous pouvez voir également
évidemment les vestiges d'une villa
gallo romaine
on a souhaité avec y compris les
habitants de d'orsay mais aussi des
associations qui travaillent autour de
ces vestiges
on a souhaité en accord avec donc
l'ensemble de ces personnes associées
maintenir ces vestiges à ciel ouvert
comme vous le voyez on les préservant
ils vont être restaurés très bientôt
c'est à dire à l'été prochain
et ça sera un lieu pour nous à la fois
de de raconter compris un passé sur le
plateau le pen le plateau était malgré
tout ce qu'on pouvait en dire et un
plateau est évidemment occupé il ya très
longtemps
c'est ici j'ai alors eu mais n'est pour
nous et symbolique aussi du passé et
évidemment d'une ville du futur que
qu'on voit se développer tous les jours
sous nos yeux
[Musique]
autre inauguration celle des équipements
publics du quartier de moulon
microcrèche groupe scolaire gymnase
mairie annexe ont encore 4200 mètres
carrés de surfaces commerciales tout a
été fait pour accueillir au mieux les
nouveaux habitants des habitants qui
sont bien décidés à rester sur le
territoire
ce matin ça a été une journée importante
pour la municipalité aussi pour les
nouveaux habitants du quartier puisque
nous avons inauguré le parc du moulon
qui est en fait le principal espace
végétal de ce quartier par la suite nous
avons pu inaugurer ondes ou moins passé
devant la mairie annexe de moulon et qui
permettra aux habitants du quartier no
cialente son dg fois de faire des
démarches administratives les cartes
d'identité et les passeports toute une
série de l'égalisation donc l'ouverture
est prévue pour février 2020 ensuite on
s'est rapproché de la future crèche du
futur pôle médical qui devrait
accueillir prochainement trois médecins
généralistes la crèche quant à elle
devant accueillir 55 perso à l'horizon 2
septembre 2020 enfin monsieur le maire a
invité les participants à inaugurer le
groupe scolaire de moulon dans lequel
nous sommes qui comprend également un
centre de loisirs et un gymnase qui est
ouvert à la fois pro public scolaire
mais aussi pour les associations
chinoises
vous y allez
on a des habitants comme dirait monsieur
le maire des vrais habitants ce qui
n'est pas faire bien entendu offense aux
étudiants mais les étudiants par
définition sont de passage donc nous
sommes ravis d'avoir des habitants à
d'honneur et puis qu'il ya 8 ans 10 des
enfants et évidemment ça permet à ce
groupe scolaire de vivre depuis
maintenant un mois avec une classe
ouverte avec 28 enfants
il y à 4200 mètres carrés de surfaces
commerciales qui est prévue sur sur la
centralité du quartier donc avec toute
une diversité de commerces coiffure il y
aura des restaurants ça c'était une
chose très importante aussi pour la vie
du quartier
il est prévu une moyenne surface
alimentaire d'environ 1000 mètres carrés
qui permettra d'offrir tous les services
attendus par la population d'un
maniement terre il y aura une pharmacie
il y aura une agence bancaire avec un
distributeur de billets bref tout un
panel de commerce que nous pouvons
retrouver d'ailleurs d'angie vallée où
surgissent chevry donc la première phase
du programme horizon et et achever la
seconde phase est en cours 2 est en
cours de réalisation et devraient être
achevés d'ici deux ans plus tard avec
notamment un point de logements
relativement important et d'où des
nouveaux habitants interne
[Musique]
et bientôt ce sera un lycée
international qui va ouvrir ses portes
dans le quartier de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau à la rentrée
scolaire 2021 1400 élèves en franchiront
les grilles de cet établissement qui se
veut un pôle d'excellence parmi ses
élèves
on retrouvera bien sûr les enfants des
chercheurs qui s'installe sur votre
territoire
la première pierre de l'établissement
vient d'être posée
[Musique]
le lycée international de palaiseau
d'accueillir à 1400 élèves avec une
fonction internationale donc des classes
préparatoires mais aussi donc du lycée
général international et 80 logements
donc
personne qui pour endormir des étudiants
qui pourront dormir sur place le but de
la dimension internationale c'est parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de chercheurs qui vont
qui habitent ce précieux de saclay pour
que leur enfant ait plus besoin d'aller
loin et épices avant leurs enfants qui
sont sur place là on est en décembre
2019 le chantier a commencé le 1er
octobre 2019
après une signature du contrat en avril
2019 toujours et donc les prochaines
étapes sa maintenance et réalisation du
gros oeuvre
actuellement c'est un grand trou on va
monter le béton on va on va fermer tout
ça ça sera à peu près au printemps de
l'année prochaine
2020 puis après on va travailler sur les
réalisations intérieur jusque jusqu'au
printemps 2021 pour une rentrée
septembre 2021 donc les élèves sera
accueilli en septembre dernier
pour nous c'était un projet exceptionnel
exceptionnel par sa situation
exceptionnelle par sa taille et
ce qui est bien sûr un disait des grands
enjeux alors l'enjeu de l'intégration de
ce projet dans le futur plateau de
saclay la parcelle est une parcelle qui
fait 100 mètres de côté et qui est
située à l'intersection entre deux
éléments majeurs de la conception
urbaine du projet à savoir la maille
piétons et un axe fédérateur horizontal
et puis ta trame de l'école
polytechnique la portion de territoire
qui va absorber cette infection
s'appelle le green
pour nous ça a été un grand plaisir de
travailler ce projet avec on dire avec
cette recherche d'évidence de lisibilité
des composantes de clarté de la
composition
et puis aussi la proposition de faire à
l'angle côté sud ouest de l'opération à
bâtiment proulx qui va recevoir des
fonctions annexes de deux lycées
administration locaux des professeurs
cdi et ce bâtiment prouve à être dans la
perspective du maï et va signifier la
présence de l'équipement et valoriser
l'apprentissage du savoir
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent ne ratez surtout
pas les trois concerts gratuits de
musique classique offert par la
communauté paris saclay le 1er janvier
les concerts ont lieu sur trois communes
l'opéra de massy à 11 heures le théâtre
de longjumeau à 15h et l'espace culturel
boris vian aux ulis à 18 heures la
programmation ne sera révélé qu'à la
dernière minute par les chefs
d'orchestre
après la musique entrée dans la matrice
l'atelier des sciences propose à la
commanderie à elancourt une exposition
innovantes en trois temps autour du
numérique et de l'intelligence
artificielle
cette exposition atelier escape room a
lieu du 15 janvier au 8 mars 2020 enfin
connaissez-vous le type tech tour de bpi
france cette tournée qui fait plus de
vingt étapes au coeur des campus
s'arrête à paris saclay ce sera le 6
février 2020 à centrale supélec
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission je
vous souhaite d'excellentes fêtes de fin
d'année nous on vous donne rendez vous
l'année prochaine
à bientôt
[Musique]